this is belper in derbyshire in 2019 it
was voted england's best high street
but the small businesses here that
survived covid lockdowns now face rising
bills
and of being pushed to the brink
things are horrendous at the moment and
food prices are just going up weekly
and i can't keep putting my menus up
because it costs me money every time i
have to have new ones printed
and
and the more i keep putting it up the
less customers are going to keep coming
in because it's obviously purses are
tightening for them at home as well
my energy bill's gone up 284
and so from 100 a month to 415 where do
we go what do we do
i don't know i have no idea what the
next steps are to be fair
it's taking every day
as it comes at the moment
new forecasts show energy prices rising
into next year hitting record levels by
april
the small businesses here need help
now
if we get some grants from the council
or governments and that would be amazing
and definitely wouldn't go and miss also
perhaps thinking out of the box and
offering some training for um social
media and our websites to help support
people that perhaps don't know how to
run those kind of things as well as they
could i think we're all having to try
and think of new ideas to bring people
in and to get sales and to encourage
people to shop with us and not forget
that we're here one small business might
employ just a handful of people but
collectively it's a sector which employs
nearly 13 million it's why the latest
forecast by the federation of small
businesses is so troubling because it
shows that 15 of those businesses are
considering either downsizing or closing
altogether over the next few months
but nearly every small business is
affected 89 say they are seeing higher
costs now than at the same time last
year under half have any intention of
trying to expand or grow and getting
access to finance like short-term loans
is a struggle between april and june
this year only 45 of financial
applications were successful
today the government told us whilst we
can't shield everyone from the global
challenges we face we're supporting
british businesses to navigate the
months ahead but times are so tough with
worse to come the reality is some
businesses will not survive this
category sky news in derbyshire